i think i need to change my ways i think
i need to make i mean i think that's the
first step is like if you're doing the
same thing expecting different results
we know the answer is but if i just wake
up every morning and i say my gratitudes
and i pray and i exercise and i
i'm already in the right
in the right path and you you you
guarantee me this will help in some way
guarantee me this is a hard guarantee
here yeah
sure all right
yeah i guarantee that this will make a
difference you know but i think the
other thing that we had started off
talking about um ego and i do think like
a
in whatever way you can do it in therapy
and journaling you can do it in 12 steps
there's so many different ways to do it
just talking to a friend but just
recognizing like
when my ego perceives a threat when i'm
in my ego when i'm in
um
my
self-will
and getting defensive prickly
and comparing myself envious all of this
stuff the stuff of ego like that needs
to be monitored you know we have to like
have like a heart monitor and be taking
the temperature of that creature and
accept it it's part of us we have egos
because we're part
chimpanzee and we want
you know we want good stuff for
ourselves and it's what's kept us alive
there's nothing evil about it but it can
dominate us and it can and it's not who
we are we are spiritual beings living a
human experience we're we're riding
around in these meat suits we get 80 90
100 years you know if you're unfortunate
like roger michelle you get 60 some
years if you're fortunate like norman
lear he's 100 years old you know but
whatever it is it's a handful of decades
in the meat suit but we're luminous
radiant beings that are beyond our ego
and so i do think that there are also
spiritual tools that you can find from
so many of the spiritual traditions that
can help us
on this to navigate this church what's a
book to read that you'd say the one book
if you're just getting into this and you
just want to find some peace what's that
one book
the dhammapada by the buddha the
dhammapada by the buddha easy read
pictures easy read no pictures but
honestly an easy read the one of the
great things about the and it's
important to read like the dhammapada
don't read like
buddha of the day quotes because most of
those are just made up and in fact
there's websites of like what is what
really did the buddha say and what's
just like made up because people were
just slapping stuff on like take a deep
breath and love yourself the buddha you
know they'll just like
slap up a new age quote and then
contribute it attribute it to the buddha
so but the the study in buddhism
is all about this um
this clutching grasping attachment to
ourselves to our wants to our egos to
the stuff of the world including what
we're where the milieu that we work in
in hollywood in terms of fame
um
but all this gla grasping clutching
wanting
never enough uh i'm not enough
comparison
um
that's all stuff of the ego and
it through some very simple perspective
shifts and exercises you can just
you can just step away from it a little
bit just kind of step outside of your
body and witness it and go oh look
there's my ego doing its thing oh bless
you ego you're trying to protect me
you're trying to take care of me i love
you but i'm not you
wow i sounded wise all of a sudden he
really did sound wise
i just i just started i was enamored
you